hey guys it's Rob did you miss me guys
hello whatever man
now but in all seriousness I really did
miss you guys but I've had like zero
time over the last couple weeks to make
any videos to have any free time for
myself I had seven finals I had two
finals one week and then I had five
finals in a row the last week and that
just drained me completely I took my
last final on Friday December 17th so
I'm now officially done with my first
semester of my second year it feels
great but I just needed some time to
unwind and to catch up on some sleep
before I made another video so I've been
sleeping 13 hours for the last couple
days so right now I'm back on Long
Island which is where I'm from
originally I'm here for break and I'm
gonna be here until about January second
or third and then after that I start
school up again I attend school in
Philadelphia and that's pretty much
where I'm going to be living for the
next two and a half years about a month
ago a fellow youtuber came to visit
Philadelphia on a road trip some of you
may know him I decided to stop by and
say hi
hey guys it's Rob and I'm Dan and we're
here in Philadelphia and it's great Dan
is actually working on a project where
he's giving his viewers and subscribers
control over his life so I've been
thinking recently about control and
about your ideas your feedback your
suggestions helping to guide me make
decisions on my channel on my future
videos that's really why I opened up the
moderator I want to see what the popular
demand is what you guys want to see what
kind of suggestions or feedback you have
for me in my trained evil Kitty video I
presented the transforming ninja star
and I asked you guys want to see this
and an overwhelming amount of people
said yeah I do want to see how to make
that so that helps me determine what
what basically the popular demand is so
I really appreciate your feedback
based on that feedback I've tried to
make my videos more understandable more
entertaining more interactive I really
want you to be able to get noticed and
to have a voice on my channel and that's
why I've also try to feature feature
your guys comments on my videos one of
the things that's been bugging me
recently has been the lie
in my videos now I'm not a professional
videographer but I definitely want to
improve the lighting because right now
I'm just using ceiling lights I'm using
lamps so I went out and I bought this
heavy-duty basically like a construction
fluorescent light so here's without and
here's with without with so I think
everything looks better with it but I
want you guys to let me know what you
think so the light is just basically
it's a big heavy-duty fluorescent lamp a
couple of days after I released the
transforming ninja star in my last video
I was looking at the ratings that it got
mmm 1 3 3 7 and 1/7 it's sweet so
apparently you guys liked the video I'd
also like to thank the will of DC for
featuring my video in his what's up
Wednesday episode 14 I had a whole bunch
of people asking me can I use printer
paper thing I could use my napkin can I
use like poster paper and the answer is
yes as long as the paper is square you
can use it and if you do use printer
paper you can get a really cool big one
like this just wanted to introduce some
of the things that I know how to make
that I haven't shown you guys yet one of
them is made out of something that you
guys already know how to make the ninja
star now this is a single sided ninja
star and it looks like I'm just holding
up two of them but they're actually
interlocked and you can actually twist
it like that and you get an
eight-pointed ninja star and this is
pretty durable um you could throw it
pretty far whoops whoops oh snap oh so
that's the eight-pointed interlocked
single sided ninja star and then there's
an eight-pointed star this is actually
made from a bird base it's pretty simple
it's a nice decoration we have the
origami modular Christmas tree and this
is really cool I like it because you can
actually build it up as bigger or as
short as you'd like and you use
different size square sheets for this
and it
pretty simple to make so they actually
slide into each other like that so
they're all modular units and you can
make it as tall as you want you can even
put like a little star on top if you'd
like it's pretty simple and I think you
guys would like it so if you want me to
show you guys how to make this or one of
the other things that I showed leaving a
comment below let me know I liked a lot
of the video responses that I got to the
transforming ninja star they were really
cool if you want your video response to
be accepted make sure that it is not a
tutorial that you created and that it
has the words are e and also the title
of my video after it that way it'll have
a better chance of getting accepted I'll
take a look at it and I might even
comment on it also I was thinking of
using some of the video responses in
future videos so let me know what you
guys think of that if you want to give
me permission in the video to do that
also that would be great I also recently
created a Twitter and a Facebook account
Twitter is linked directly to YouTube
the Facebook however is not so I'm going
to be posting pictures of things that I
might put on YouTube so if you want the
inside scoop be sure to go on Facebook
and like Rob's world I'll have links to
those in the upper right part of the
banner on my channel my older brother is
on YouTube now his channel name is my
name plus big brothers so check him out
at Rob h0 629 big brother he's in my
other channel box and also in the video
description below so show some support
subscribe I'm going to be breaking
50,000 subscribers coming up in a few
weeks I believe and I definitely want to
do some sort of giveaway I'm still
trying to come up with some ideas of
what I should give away but I definitely
was thinking of doing a t-shirt coming
up soon I got the idea from a guy named
Rhonda he told me to check out
zazzle.com so I checked it out warning
paper ninja stars are very sharp and
will poke your eye out if you're not
careful this is not a final design just
a test I know I asked a lot of questions
in this video but I'm just trying to
figure out if you guys like this new
format that I'm trying where I do a
tutorial and then I switch it up and do
an update video where I feature some of
the comments from the tutorial possibly
even some of the video responses so if
you do like it leave me a comment let me
know give me a thumbs up I real
enjoy hearing from you guys and the
quicker that you guys let me know what
you want to see I can get on it as soon
as possible
this video took a little bit longer than
expected it's already Christmas Eve so I
hope you have a wonderful Christmas or a
wonderful break whatever you guys are
celebrating and I hope you get to enjoy
it with your family so here are some of
the comments from the transforming ninja
star tutorial
[Music]
you